e se eu falar cultura chinesa o que que
vem na mente de vocês e deu gramas
grandes indústrias templos antigos que
esse kung fu
e a verdade pegou trouxinhas e permanece
muito misteriosa e do desconhecido para
a maioria dos ocidentais
e isso acontece por dois motivos
principais o primeiro é que o pensamento
chinês e o nosso pensamento tem origem
absolutamente diferentes o nosso
pensamento pebl da cultura greco-romana
da europa a visão da metafísica que
separa o corpo ea mente e usa a lógica e
o resto zinho dedutivo para observar e
analisar a realidade já comprou este
lisa é um pensamento paradoxal que não
separar mente corpo espírito entendi
depois as apostas podem coexistir e na
verdade isso acontece o tempo todo além
disso
o chineses tinham o hábito de uma bem
segredos e os conhecimentos mais
importantes dentro de um trabalho em
ofício uma arte uma filosofia aquilo que
é realmente essencial só era transmitido
aqueles que eram considerados
merecedores daquele saber
e nós somos professores de tai chi chuan
estilo que faz estamos a gente for da
família achei ele só foi aberto para a
população algumas teclas então nós temos
hoje vitória a chance de conhecer um
pouco da cultura de levar e aí eu vou
tentar vocês e vocês me diriam se eu
dissesse e a um exercício onde com menos
de dez minutos você consegue melhorar
sua forma física respiração só de
clareza mental
é isso você que hoje né vendo o mundo
para outro prisma procurando buscando
formas e se conheceres entender nós
vamos passar vamos estar presente a luz
ou uma dessas contas eu não pedi de
vocês duas coisas primeiro a gente vai
precisar que todos vocês estejam
respirando então mim não ficar esperando
pode levantar não que eu vou aí ajudar
com pelo jeito tá tudo no esperando
muito bom começamos bem a segunda coisa
que a gente precisa que vocês estejam um
corpo era a cabeça em cima a cintura em
baixo e coluna que preferência esticar
o seu jeito todo estão assim eu já
começamos muito bem então outra coisa
para quem puder por favor se levante
e aí
é isso observe o pedro e conta com todos
os comandos afasta as suas pernas a
largura dos ombros isso os juros
levemente flexionados ao se sentar em um
banquinho
é isso que quiser pode tirar o sapato tá
bom os pés é que está firme no chão e
contato com o solo
e vocês vão levantar os braços de forma
leve suave
e com seus pulsos estivessem amarradas
por um fio as mãos se levantam
oi e para na altura do peito as palmas
viram para você relaxe os ombros e os
provemos a ponta para baixo
e vocês vão fechar os olhos
e vão se concentrar só na sua respiração
o e aproveitaremos esse tempo para fazer
nada
é muito bem abre os olhos recebimento
abaixe os braços regulagem nos ombros o
corpo e pode acertar o
eu imagino que você fez no mercado um
pouco de dores e tensões nos outros
espelho vai dar força esse movimento
nosso presente para vocês ele conhecido
em comum tarde lá no
e os bons estão mistas estranham
framboesas séculos está no currículo
marcial houve vários estilos de vacinar
7 vezes essa possui coisa acabaram de
fazer depois tem como principal é
abraçar a árvore' e aí parece absurdo né
com uma coisa assim tão simples pode
trazer benefícios para o corpo pra mente
alimentar nossa vida será que só faz
sentido a gente vai explicar isso
através de dois conselhos o whey
traduzido como não nossa e o yan talvez
você já conheça só consegui escutar o
mesmo o talvez vou é sei se do
pensamento chinês estava sendo observado
no mundo e chegavam conclusões sobre
como a existência funciona e uma coisa
que eles perceberam que é muito central
é que a mudança é interruptor na
realidade tudo o tempo todo
a bola e se move mesmo que não possamos
perceber
e esse mundo uma cotação com uma
respiração e sol esses valorizavam a
simplicidade e naturalidade a humildade
ea moderação com as características de
um sábio e para eles assuntos sabe é a
não ação
e essa pulsação eles concluíram também
que ela tanto que não tendência assim
equilibrar esses complemente
naturalmente
e também interessante alguém aqui já que
eu fui ao momento trabalhar faz os dias
várias horas e eu sem parar a trabalhar
estudar e sem parar sem parar e de
repente a dois eu comento uso ou por
algum motivo não conseguiu mais estudar
e trabalhar por um longo período
em uma sociedade excessivamente
consumista ou menos como minimalismo o
crescimento da mesma
e comente criciúma natureza
e aí corrigir mais explodindo e vai
limpando vai ganhando espaço
já aconteceu atualmente essa pulsação
mas eu temos controle sobre ela é
suprindo ela é a base de um ano que
existe a gente tenta controlar a gente
tá mal nos cabem intensiva e acompanhar
esse ritmo
e é isso não assunto é isso você estar
ali presente percebendo e acompanhando o
ritmo da natureza é dormir quando a
gente tem sono comigo quando a gente tem
fome bebê quando a gente tem sede só às
vezes você fácil mas se a gente
acompanha corrente pequenas ações podem
tirar imensos resultados com devia
lauser o caminho é uma constante no ação
que nada deixa por realizar
se nós formos observar a mata as
florestas as árvores crescem no silêncio
e podemos compreender muito passados e
verá que elas estão em constante
medicação elas não reclama eles estão
quietas elas aproveita quando tem chuva
e se nutra o sol vem e elas crescem e
florescem quando chego inverno mesmo que
suas folhas caem elas estão reclamam e
elas esperam pacientemente porque a
primavera vai chegar então nessa clima
quetude onde parece nada esse móvel
talvez o farfalhar causa do vento ele se
parece com a posição que você acabar de
fazer estática e moro você talvez não
consiga ver movimento isso porque ele
deve ter um
e as árvores estão constantemente
fazendo troca ambiente dando frutos
emagrecer planeta eu tô sombra é uma
alquimia do movimento natural assim como
já ouviu algo que me terra tem movimento
você pode tá parar faz dentro de você
aqui um relaxamento que aconteceu meus
pais você tá pegando a sua respiração e
não faz burro como eu disse ok interno e
essa costura muito simples justamente
então não vai te trazer nada de novo é
verdade é uma oportunidade que você se
concede países faziam de se desprendendo
de hábitos de posturas desligadas
inadequadas que você foi se adaptando e
se viciando nelas de posturas mentais
que você construiu longo da vida que
pode até ter sido importantes em algum
momento mas que já não tem nada a ver
com o momento que tá acontecendo
me conta uma história presente ficar
tudo isso a nossa história mas nos
conhecemos 16 anos atrás no seminário de
tai chi chuan que o espírito santo e
participando de um grupo disso tudo
junto e depois de um desses grupos de
estudos a gente começou a conversar eu
praticamente gentileza é tu tava lá no
ponto ou e a gente percebeu que os dois
eram apaixonados pela liturgia nós vamos
fascinada por tudo aquilo que iremos
bebidas com gin
e-books com essas pessoas feridas e
pedro me chama para voltar a treinar
firme ele é um seminário no sul do país
que o nosso grão-mestre uma raid 1 e
precisa ficar melhor de nós conversar
treinar frequentemente todos os dias ele
volta o seminário extremamente ilhado o
review todos os benefícios que ele podia
ter um caixinha ele queria porque queria
compartilhar isso com maior número de
pessoas e passei fazemos nisso há 3 anos
atrás essa turma quando a gente usou era
só um trem pelo cenário mas ele chamou
alguns amigos eles compareceram viram
três viam 1 a 5 nenhuma pessoa e
continuada o espaço que a gente pratica
pedra cebolas faça o público então às
vezes tinha festa de aniversário a gente
tava treinando quando a chuva vem a
gente tinha que cancelar o trem ou mudar
de local mas a gente fez estilo chegou
no fim do ano essa aulas estavam 15 2018
pessoas acham
e daqui e não fez nenhum esforço
consciente dessa direção aí foi aí que
nós erramos porque nós saímos da
animação e começamos a ter uma ação
excessiva nós queremos começar o ano com
o pé direito então conseguimos um espaço
centro de lutas mas havemos mais
horários as fixamos um valor nós
queremos profissionalizar o mais cheio
oi e aí nessa pulsação constante estava
no ápice da expansão então responde
ainda mais caiu misturar os alunos
começaram a comparecer a gente não
conseguir treinar junto porque eram mais
aulas utilizava as aulas e aquilo que
era um grande prazer de praticar e
compartilhar tudo isso que a gente tinha
aprendido começa a se tornar outro par
uma coisa difícil o dia de dar aula a
gente vai ficar assim minha irmã meu
deus e ao mesmo tempo a gente não se diz
que o mercado está naquele instante que
tinha medo de falar um com o outro de
quem tava desanimado de que talvez não
tem nada pô então no sábado onde vai
ficar grandes aulas cancelando as aulas
vamos os dois agradecer bom então quando
ele chegou se olhou e começou a
conversar do nosso a 15 minutos para
resolver tudo porque os dois estavam
muito internet para frio esse vez
palavras fazemos as resolvemos vamos
fazer lá tudo você dirigir não tava
naquele local local e maravilhoso mas
era nosso
bom então o nome da turma voltamos para
minha cebola somente aos sábados ou
temos a nova gostosa agradável que nós
estamos gostando começamos a estudar o
nossos alunos aí as coisas voltaram zx
os alunos voltaram a frequentar com mais
constância tu não aparecia tá assim
novamente andando bem mas como a
realidade sempre mudo como está o estás
bem observarão as mudanças vieram e eu
mudei bruxo teve tem marechal floriano a
uma hora e meia de distância quantas
coisas espinha uma estabilizaram eu não
ia poder mais da aula
e enquanto isso no ano que vem eu
estaria mudando da por consequência toda
a causa da aula e o que acabar só eu
gostava mais velho juca tem que saber
disso tava acontecendo ele foi no
movimento próprio astronautas a gente
tava quieto e não tinha nem começado
porque eu tava lá em marechal e ele tava
aqui juntos eles conversar muito e
quando a gente não fez nada para
resolver a situação se resolver sozinha
viu aquele sentiu na pele os benefícios
ele quis transmitir isso também começou
a puxar uns treinos e hoje as alças ele
puxa tão ainda mais cheias de pessoas
então percebo no momento que tava tudo
bom nós estamos interferir e as coisas
desandaram um ano que parecia quieto me
acabar definitivamente porque os
professores iam para onde nós não
fizemos nada e tudo se resolveu sozinho
e curioso então os momentos favoráveis e
desfavoráveis a gente tem que dar
conectado no presente
é realmente levar a gente pode não
aproveitar um momento ou tornar um
momento de agora aguenta pior por
exemplo se você tá andando no trânsito e
vi um carro de festa de repente você
esfrega tão aquele susto se a seguir
esse cara é louco é um tronco de
coqueiro podia ter batido podia ter
quebrado meu carro eu perder o dia
inteiro para resolver e gastar um monte
de dinheiro a partir do momento que a
batida não aconteceu toda se resto é
apenas a sua imaginação te levando mas
isso ainda assim mexe com seus
sentimentos ainda assim diz para
sistemas do seu corpo dispersa sua
energia e você entra numa batalha
impossível de vocês assim uma batalha
imaginaria pronto inimigo que não existe
olá tudo excesso mental gasta mais
energia e hoje em dia nós estamos sendo
bombardeada constantemente por
informação passamos um dia rodando feed
de notícias
e o tempo inteiro passamos convidados
pelas notificações as redes sociais até
olhando mas acabamos nos perdendo neste
mar de informação constante interrompida
é isso sai fora do padrão da doação não
é à toa e você tem um aumento dos níveis
de ansiedade estresse depressão annaud
insônia eu acho que hoje em dia as
doenças mentais estão em alta o disse
saímos atuação e passamos ação excessiva
nós nos orgulhamos e batemos no peito
para falar que trabalhamos horas a filme
e isso só acabando com a nossa saúde e
nossa sanidade por isso que estamos aqui
hoje para compartilhar uma pílula do
silêncio da távola
a centrar vocês e essa fila aí vocês
cada um de vocês
com essa onda de excessos faz acabam do
pt então vamos pegando um dia simples e
tomamos um relevante e no tion
e o tiago é muito simples a parado em pé
mas ele assim ele pode ser o remédio uma
grande variedade de mais que tem a ver
com a sua forma de virgínia mas por esse
remédio funcionar vocês enfeitar
aparentemente milagrosos tem uma coisa
que é fundamental
não existe uma seguinte essa semente
também volta na terra e régua uma vez o
outro é uma bike isso é uma semente
crescer é fácil é você regar um
pouquinho toda dizer então isso tudo que
está falando a partir do dia anjo pode
acontecer desde que vocês dediquem um
pouco todo dia que não frequência
constância na prática jurídica
a gente aprendeu com as árvores são um
ótimo exemplo da não-ação nós podemos
aprender ainda mais mas as árvores têm
um poder limitado por influenciar a
realidade elas são mais passivas nós
como humanos temos um grande poder de
influência a realidade a partir de uma
mudança que começa dentro de nós assim
como uma pedra que atiraram no lado a
pequena pedro lá denor pode geraldo
ações que vão se esconde indo até
alcançar todo lá nós começamos a
praticar e sentiram que essa mudança
nosso pensamento nosso sentimento as
nossas ações isso começa a tocar as
pessoas ao nosso redor elas percebem ela
sim subiu ela se contagiam e a partir de
uma pequena ou dessa dentro de nós
escolhemos criar ondas e conversar
ilimitadamente todo mundo é assim que
apenas uma árvore
e pode mudar o mundo inteiro
g1
e aí